[Musique]
on a tous une opinion sur la pandémie de
covè 19 mais ça ne fait pas de tout le
monde et de n'importe qui des experts
vous êtes nombreux
jour après jour à nous questionner sur
des vidéos virales publiée sur youtube
et qui porte sur le nouveau camp à virus
celle qui ressort le plus du lot c'est
celle ci mise en ligne par un certain
pascal borrell oui mais la deuxième
vague d'infection est celle qui est
véritablement létale pascal morel vite
en suisse il se décrit comme un ancien
importateurs d'ananas qui a dit il et je
souhaite étudier la science de façon
autodidacte dans cette vidéo vue à près
de deux millions de reprises
il répand une série de questions à
propos de la pandémie de kobe de 19
villes plusieurs des conseils qu'il
donne sont en phase oui avec ce que
suggèrent les autorités de santé
publique
mais les explications que monsieur borel
offre sur la nature de l'infection ne
tiennent pas la route et sont carrément
alarmiste selon tatiana scorza une
immunologue interviewé par mon collègue
des fixes notamment monsieur bord elle
affirme que le véritable fléau de la
coved 19 débutera quand les gens vivront
une deuxième ou encore une troisième
exposition au virus
pour lui le virus pourrait entrer dans
les cellules humaines par 5 récepteur au
lieu d'un seul
il ajoute ensuite que deuxième réflexion
du cornât virus causera nécessairement
des hémorragies intestinales et même un
arrêt cardiaque
vous avez été plusieurs à nous avoir
fait part de vos craintes par rapport à
cette déclaration
ensuite s'il est vrai que le virus peut
entrer dans les cellules de plusieurs
façons le système immunitaire est en
mesure selon elle de reconnaître et
générer des anticorps et des réponses
cellulaire contre les protéines du virus
pouvant utiliser ces autres voies
d'interaction avec nos cellules
cela dit il est tout à fait vrai que
certaines personnes sont susceptibles de
développer une deuxième fois la copie de
19 à cause d'une immunité imparfaite
mais selon madame scorza assurer de
façon si catégoriques comme le fait
pascal borrell que chez certains
individus la deuxième réflexion serait
fatal ça va contre le principe de
l'immunité adaptative
morale de l'histoire porter un regard
critique sur les individus sans
expertise scientifique formelle qui
s'improvisent etc
r dans leur salon n'oubliez pas de jeter
un coup d'oeil à l'article de jeff reed
et continuer à nous écrire notre boîte
courriel et notre groupe facebook vous
attend salut